étant donné que sur la vidéo d'un vent
sur le mode border vous n'arrêtez pas de
me tuer 1 parce que vous aimez ça hein
évidemment maintenant ma technique se
dire que je suis tout le temps vers
trier donc voilà kg je suis le meurtrier
attention je ne le suis peut-être pas
mondial auquel est max à partir je suis
meurtriers au monde 2 à ces mots c'est
quoi c'est quoi ce prono les biens par
le collège attendons bien sûr le lien
attends je mika dégage c'est chaud je
suis sur edel chobo le meurtrier il
tente un truc je t'ai vu piquer sans
trop faire qu'est ce que tu as alors
gros torticolis la aux jeunes meurtriers
les mecs
[ __ ] je marque et c'est celle 8l
meurtrier bah oui c'est moi allez c'est
bon je suis là à moi je vais dans mon
placard non c'est mika série qui à leur
mépris sauf personnes parmi eux le mec
m'a tuer il m'a tuer en 5 secondes quoi
c'était quoi cette ligue mondiale
mais c'est pas moi mon gars et je vous
jure alors oui je dis tu vois mon balai
steak je suis trop bien installée
maintenant je dors je dors d'une manière
très confortable de bien aux effets de
ricochet le cas ricochet ça rentrait
ricochet j'ai dégoté ton copain
revient la droite et la droite dans le
coin non mais les mets un coup de
couteau n'a pas entendu le bruit et le
choc du coup de couteau aux médias non
mais tu sais pas ils disaient oui bon
les mecs les congrès un petit jour les
pondérant offert des kings x trail il
accueille là dessus et hugo il s'est
arrêté il va fixer pendant 20 secondes
bec
c'était beaucoup plus intense de toute
ma vie pas toujours dans le milieu
non mais non prévus sur son chemin non
les mecs tarte un certain tuer tout le
monde je n'y crois pas mais comment cela
est il pousse la peur parce que tu as
peur parce que tu as peur non est ce que
tu avais cool mais on est tous les trois
là il y aura un meurtrier à temps
cassez-vous j'ai pas confiance
moi j'accuse toujours le chaud mois mais
qu'a fait moins besoin d'avions
d'affaires a choisi ces petits insectes
étaient ouvertes mais c'est moins deux
mois
ah ben oui c'est moi
c'est la première fois en 48 heures de
jeu j'ai réussi à faire un ticket avec
la grille et pour une fois il voulait un
bisou il a appris un bisou prise et
qu'il est bon mika pour me faire
pardonner pour me faire pardonner mois
ci des bananes voilà alors j'ai donné ma
vie pour toi c'est qui paye ton ticket
d'accès qui québec ski québec m mais
qu'à mon trou et à l'aide de cacher la
joconde une porte derrière moi je te
cover en peluche et en tirant d'élite
donc à votre problème tel tableau
d'offres au québec telus québec tu m'as
la hâte et québec tu t'isoles vélib
sayabec citizen d'élite certains au
petit monde bien du mal à acheter
non c'était pour l'a été je vise et les
bonnets je vais pas de calais à t1 à toi
palestine halte d'élite est commença à
pratiquer la myopie eu l'air correct et
latady donc je vais si je vais de
bloquer dans la cabane a fait des bébés
et même bouteille ça tue les cent vingt
années à cecon bien moi je suis un vase
non c'est pas vrai aux hommes
on est bien là ben moi je suis bloqué
moi aussi je suis bloqué à moi aussi je
suis bloqué à mika alors il va nous tuer
il s'approchait de du vase comme pour
l'inspecter l'homme avec une arme que ce
n'était pas un match il avait rien vu
c'était une très bonne stratégie mais
qui a une ossature bois auquel ben oui
moi je veux bien qu plusieurs médecins
ban il est ahurissant youtube et a volé
la banane mais banane c'est lui qui a
suivi car il est où il est tout cas du
cac on parie combien c'est hugo tulle
golf du gop écoute moi tu le mets 4 ta
gueule non je savais que c'était pas
mika je savais que c'était pas moi
parce que je sais que dans ta voix j'ai
senti une certaine émotion
quant à paris j'avais comme ceux qui
avaient une musique un peu triste
derrière et tous cas les cas on parie
combien
or c'est donc pas lui j'en suis sûr
alesha qu'à son tour allez c'est une
femme est un connard prochain jean
charles naouri qu'elle reviendrait à
droite la houlala
le petit regret qu'il allait dire un
passage secret de ouf et ou minou mais
tu vas pas vu mais je suis bloqué les
bloquer c'est la thèse de la paix
c'était bien qu'il a fait tu rentres
regarde que m regarde là non merde gare
de ouf de biens magnette se ressemblent
et en maïs ne doit pas faire un bilan et
l'orgueil il est là il y avait cherché
des faits en bref je vais vider les gs
je veux pas l'auteur béton n'avait pas
de contrainte ça c'est moi je suis élu
maire carthage étaient encore tués alors
qu'ils étaient innocents mais alors ça
fait quoi
ça fait quoi de ressentir ce que je
ressens à chaque fois tai chi est
éliminé tu et à toi tu seras pas de mine
demeure de recul chez les barbares qui
n'a bon mec jégun moi qui fait la loi
chez riot là donc c'est le cas c'est le
cas chez reed qu'est ce qu'il a
c'est le cas c'est comme mais pourquoi
les haies mais lui il m'énerve ça
puisque je détruis trois fois il veut
trop que je meure pourrait encore j'en
ai c'est luca jean luc à rien depuis
quatre ans à paris je cherche des
indices mais rien n'est acquis ou si oui
je n'aurais jamais regardé la travée
ouest vous les enfants
mais qu'a bien prendre le gan michael
est là mais car oui j'ai une bière
chengere apparemment tu as bien t'as pas
trop protégé n'avait pas non plus fait
un tonneau je suis pas célibataire et le
mc gilles dionne maintenant cannes berne
n'entend pas la gueule si j'ai une
gueule ce que je devais encore aaa herbe
à chaque fois une clinique où mon trip
de chéri je n'écris pas des fois ça
marche pas alors c'était quoi ça se
passe bien on peut en parler si tu veux
je peux faire le rôle de psy cieux c'est
lui quand il se déplace cowes singes à
temps qui revient dans ce cadre qu'ils
viennent voilà à
c'est moi le meurtrier iv cartes sur
tables cassées qui me c'est toi regarde
aller les olympiens moitié moitié et on
sait qu'à chaque fois ces groupes ce qui
parle restez pas et voient ce témoin à
l'anp remballe ta théorie
ah bah oui il a pas le cas non je ne
sais pas pourquoi il a disparu
[Musique]
lapipe
oh